this video is brought to you by
manscapes.com
the global brand for men's grooming and
hygiene products
hey 42 here don't you just love
christmas it's my favorite time of the
year
the tinsel the carols the eggnog
the delicious reindeer stew but for one
family in west virginia
christmas eve was anything but merry
instead of a heartwarming time around
the fire
they were met with a blaze of very
different proportions
a catastrophe that tore their lives
apart and ignited an enduring mystery
that remains unsolved to this day
it was the 24th of december 1945
and the soda family of fayetteville west
virginia
was home enjoying the evening before
christmas
george soder was a successful
businessman who
along with his wife jenny presided over
a respected middle-class family
of 10 children yes 10 children
nine of those children were at home this
fateful night
with only 21 year old joseph being
absent while serving in the army
as christmas eve drew to a close three
of the kids
12 year old martha 80 year old jenny and
five-year-old betty
were playing with the gifts given to
them by their sister marion
who at 17 was the eldest daughter
after a long day's work together george
and his two
older boys 23 year old john and 16 year
old
george jr had already gone to bed at 10
p.m the young girls begged to stay up
later than usual
to play with their new toys which their
mum
jenny agreed to provided that two boys
14 year old maurice and nine-year-old
louis
did the final farm duties before turning
in
then jenny said good night to the kids
and took sylvia
her youngest to bed it was by any one
standard
an idyllic family scene
[Music]
at around 12 30 that night the phone
rang
jenny went downstairs to answer the call
and was greeted by the sound of laughter
and glasses clinking in the background a
woman's voice that jenny didn't
recognize
asked for a name she'd never heard of
jenny said she had the wrong number and
the woman gave what jenny later called
a weird laugh before hanging up the
phone
on her way back up to bed jenny noticed
that the lights in the house were still
on the door was unlocked and the
curtains were still open
and that was strange if the children
ever stayed up late they always
took care of these details before going
up to the attic where they all slept
but 17 year old marion had fallen asleep
on the living room couch
and jenny assumed the other kids had
gone off to bed
forgetting these minor chores and the
excitement of christmas
so she turned off the lights locked the
door closed the curtains and went back
up to bed
as you'll all know by now i'm a huge fan
of manscaped
they offer the best tools and solutions
for the big free odor zones
your body butt and balls and
their new lawnmower 4.0 waterproof
electric trimmer
is no exception what's more you can now
get the ultimate manscaped experience
when you purchase their new
performance package 4.0 bundle firstly
you can start your grooming in the
shower with the new lawnmower 4.0
it's a waterproof cordless trimmer and
it makes it so easy to tackle your
groin grooming with confidence without
any messes
it also comes with a cool new wireless
charging system
and a new travel lock feature it's the
future of the trimming game
trust me and after your shower you can
treat yourself
by applying the manscaped crop preserver
ball deodorant
it's a quick absorbing clear drying
moisturizer lotion
for all day protection and for a little
midday refresher you can always pack
your crop reviver ball toner spray this
spray is a real revitalizer with its
cooling aloe vera
and anti-inflammatory properties trust
me your balls will thank you
but manscaped is so much more than a
ball trimmer company
in fact their new performance package
4.0 bundle
now includes their new weed whacker nose
and
ear hair trimmer this thing is an
absolute game changer for tackling those
pesky nose hairs
without any pain for a limited time you
can get not one but
two free gifts the shed travel bag and
the manscaped anti-chafing boxer briefs
all you need to do is head to
manscape.com forward slash
42 today to get 20
off free international shipping plus
these two free gifts
your balls and your body will thank you
just half an hour later jenny was woken
again
this time by something hitting the roof
she later described it as sounding like
a heavy rubber ball
which then rolled off the roof and hit
the ground with a foot
she listened for another noise but when
the night remained
still she drifted back off to sleep
another half hour later jenny woke up
again
this time to the smell of smoke after
scrambling out of bed she discovered
that the room
george used for an office was on fire
panicked she woke george who then woke
the two eldest sons
john and george jr jenny woke marion
and told her to get baby sylvia out of
the house
everyone yelled for the children
upstairs in the attic
but there was no answer initially after
the fire john said he'd gone into the
children's room and
shaken them awake but later he changed
this story to say
he'd only called up to them a pretty
critical piece of evidence
as we'll see later george
jenny and the other four children
escaped the house
but the remaining five children were
nowhere to be seen
by now the entire downstairs was in
flames
as was the staircase that led up to
where the five children slept
george and his sons tried to re-enter
the house through an asic window
which george smashed slicing his arm
open in the process
the plan was to climb in through the
window using the ladder that was
always kept at the side of the house
except that ladder was nowhere to be
seen
george had the idea to drive his trucks
up to the house and used them to climb
up into the attic window
but despite working perfectly the day
before
neither truck would start in desperation
george tried to use water from an
outside barrel to extinguish to flames
but being the middle of west virginia in
winter
the water was frozen solid george
jenny and their four children could do
nothing
more than stand by and watch watches
their house
burnt to the ground within 45 minutes
it was over the house had collapsed
taking with it
the sodders believed their youngest five
children
thanks to the second world war which had
ended only months before
the fayetteville fire department was
understaffed
and relied on a telephone chain with
each firefighter
taking turns to call others to spread
the word
to make masses worse the fire chief cj
morris
didn't know how to drive the fire truck
and needed to wait for someone more
qualified to arrive
the result of this comedy of
catastrophes was that firefighters only
arrived at the scene
between seven and nine am on christmas
day
at least six hours after the fire had
started
by then there was nothing to be done
what had once been the sodder home was
now little more than a pile of
smoldering ash and ruins
ash and ruins but
weirdly enough no bones
at least none that the firefighters
could find
not that that necessarily meant the
children had survived
how could they have their house had
burnt down
and they were nowhere to be seen by 10
am
chief morris told the devastated parents
that their five children had died in the
fire
their bones having turned to ash in the
blaze
a few days later a coroner's inquest was
convened and the jury determined that
the cause of the fire
was an electrical fault by the 30th of
december
death certificates for the five children
were issued
and on the 2nd of january a funeral was
held
though george and jenny sodder were too
grief-stricken to attend
the events of that terrible christmas
were devastating
and had happened terrifyingly quickly
but as george and jenny sodder
began rebuilding their lives they
started piecing together
what had happened and in the sober light
of day
it no longer seemed so obvious that
their five children
had perished in the blaze there were
simply
too many details on the case that didn't
make
sense to start with the ladder that was
mysteriously missing from the side of
the house on the night of the disaster
the same ladder that was never moved and
would potentially
have allowed george to climb into the
attic to save his children
was found down an embankment more than
20 meters
from where it was usually kept on the
night of the fire
marion had run to a neighbor's house to
call the fire department
but the phone line was down a passing
motorist had seen the flames
and had tried to call the fire
department from a nearby tavern
but he couldn't get through either in
the end another neighbor had to drive
into town
and track down the fire chief in person
it later transpired that none of the
local phones were working
not because of the fire but because
someone had
cut the local phone lines george was
also convinced his trucks had been
tampered with
he was diligent about looking after his
business equipment
and it simply didn't make sense that
both trucks would
suddenly fail to start when they'd been
working perfectly the day before
around the time of the fire neighbors
had seen a man sneaking away from the
scene with a block and tackle
the kind that's commonly used to remove
motor engines
it turns out he was simply stealing it
but when the police caught up with him
he also admitted to having severed the
phone lines
though he claims he thought they were
power lines
frustratingly it seems no one thought to
ask him
why he wanted to cut the power to the
house
even more frustratingly no official
record survives identifying the mystery
block and tackle thief
so nobody has ever been able to track
him down to find out just what the hell
he was up to that night
these strange occurrences on their own
proved nothing
but taking them all together they began
to sow seeds of doubt
in the soda family's minds
and there was more
according to fire chief morris and the
coroner's inquiry
the fire had been caused by an
electrical failure
but when the family had been trying to
escape the house
all the lights were working even on the
christmas tree
how could there have been an electrical
failure if the electricity was working
just fine
long after the fire had started
jenny soda disputed another aspect of
the fire chief morris's report
that the remains of the five dead
children had been burnt up in the blaze
in another incident around the same time
a family of seven were burnt to death in
a similar fire
and remains of all of those dead
had been found an employee at a local
crematorium
told jenny that human bones still remain
after bodies are burnt at 1 000 degrees
celsius
for two hours much hotter
and much longer than the soda fire had
been
obsessed jenny began a process of
burning small piles of different animal
bones
trying to destroy them completely
she never succeeded the more the family
investigated the fire
the more convinced they became that's
their five children
had not been taken by it the question
was where were they the sodders
suspicions that an electrical fault had
not caused a fire
seemed to be confirmed when a bus driver
claims he'd seen people
throwing what he described as balls of
fire at the house
which made it sound like a dungeons and
dragons level 5
mage had been behind the incident
that is until the seasons changed and
melting snow revealed a small round
object
in the bushes near the house george
recognizes it once
it was a pineapple bomb a type of hand
grenade used in the war
could it have been responsible for the
loud thump jenny heard on the roof the
night of the fire
and even the fire itself
of course all of this weirdness leads us
to the inevitable question
why would anyone want to sabotage the
sudden house
everything we've learned so far the
strange phone call
the cut power lines the possibly
sabotaged trucks
and the presence of a hand grenade in a
family garden
it's all a bit odd but if these really
are
clues pointing to a secret scheme to
whisk away five of the soda children
someone was apparently prepared to go to
extreme
lengths to do so not only did they have
to create
the mother of all diversions they also
appear to have thought of
every last detail from hiding the ladder
to sabotaging the trucks
just in case george sodder happened to
think of using their vehicles to reach
the kids
the most common place people have gone
seeking
possible motives for such an elaborate
crime
is in george sodder's somewhat shady
past
george soder was originally giorgio
soduc
an immigrant who moved to the united
states from sardinia
in by 1945 he built himself a successful
truck hauling business in fayetteville
and had become a well-known member of
the local italian-american community
but george was an outspoken man who
publicly criticized
italy's fascist dictator benito
mussolini
mussolini was a polarizing figure
amongst italians at the time
eliciting love and hatred in equal
measure
ilducci as he was known was executed by
communist partisans
in april 1945 but
by christmas of that year the dramatic
event
still felt very fresh for many italians
so george sodder's views made him
unpopular amongst mussolini loyalists
something that was made very clear to
him
[Music]
just weeks before the fire a salesman
arrived at the soda residence
and tried to sell george life insurance
when george turned him down the man
claims the sodder house would go up in
smoke
and the children would be destroyed as
punishment for the things george had
said
about mussolini later it emerged that
the same salesman had been a juror in
the coroner's inquiry
that had concluded the fire had been
caused by faulty wiring this was
especially suspicious
as a few months before the fire a man
had shown up at the house
looking for work when george said he
didn't have any
the man had pointed up to the fuse box
outside the house out of nowhere
and told george it was going to cause a
fire one day
despite the fact it was in good repair
and had been checked by the local power
company
only weeks before the older sodder boys
also recalled having seen a suspicious
car
parked on the side of the highway near
their house
for a number of days before christmas
the driver had
apparently been watching the younger
sodder kids closely
as they came home from school
by now george and jenny were convinced
their children were still alive
a conclusion that was strengthened as
eyewitness reports began to flood in
one woman claimed to have seen the
children in a passing
car whilst the fire was in progress
another woman who managed a tourist shop
about 50 miles west of fayetteville said
she'd seen the children the morning
after the fire and had even served them
breakfast
yet another woman from a hotel in the
nearby town of charleston
claimed to have seen four of the five
children about a week after the fire
accompanied by four people of italian
descent
when she tried to speak to the children
one of the men became hostile
and said something to them in italian at
which point the children stopped
communicating and
moved on sightings like these spurred
the sodders on
they approached the fbi requesting
assistance
and even though fbi director j edgar
hoover
himself replied personally to say he
didn't think he could help
he did make his agents available at the
discretion of local law enforcement
the fayetteville police and fire
departments however
refused fbi involvement
george and jenny soder also hired a
private investigator to hunt down leads
though none of these amounted to
anything much the investigator did
uncover a bizarre story involving fire
chief morris
morris had apparently told the local
minister
that despite claiming to have not found
any remains after the fire
he had in fact found a human heart which
he buried in a box near the site
when the sodders approached the fire
chief he agreed to dig it up
and inside they found what later turned
out
to be fresh beef liver eventually morris
admitted he'd fabricated the whole thing
to try to get the sodders
to stop making inquiries further
fuelling suspicions of a local cover-up
over the following years tips and leads
came in from
all over the united states and george
sodder travelled the country
in desperate hope of finding some clue
that proved his children were still
alive
without success in august 1949 almost
four years after the fire
george and jenny had an idea they hoped
would confirm
once and for all that their children had
not
died on that fateful night four days
after the tragedy
george had used a bulldozer to cover the
ruins of the house
in several feet of dirt now desperate
for the truth
he hired a pathologist from washington
dc
to oversee the excavation of the site
and look for skeletal remains
in yet another strange twist the
pathologists found
shards of vertebrae which were sent to
the smithsonian
institute for analysis scientists
confirmed that the bones belonged to a
boy
but most likely one that was too old to
have been any of the sodder children
the smithsonian also confirmed the bones
had never been exposed to fire
suggesting the vertebrae must have
already been in the earth george had
moved with the bulldozer
or perhaps if you're feeling cynical
that someone had planted them there in
the hope of convincing the sodders
that they'd found their children's
remains
no matter how many setbacks the sodders
faced in the pursuit of the truth
they kept on fighting to find their
children
they erected a large billboard on route
16 a road that ran by the site of the
fire
it showed the faces of their five
missing children and offered a ten
thousand dollar reward for information
that might lead to their discovery over
the course of some 40 years design
became a kind of
local landmark more than 20 years after
the event
jenny received an envelope in the post
with a photograph of a young man in his
thirties
the envelope was postmarked kentucky but
had no other identifying features
on the back of the photograph was a
handwritten note that included the name
louis sodder and the cryptic message
that made no sense to the sodder family
george and jenny were convinced the man
in the image
was their son louie but didn't publicize
the fact for fear of getting him into
trouble
george sodder died the following year in
and jenny retreated from the world and
remained in mourning
wearing black from the day after the
fire
until the day she died in 1989
the remaining sodder children kept the
memory of the case active
never giving up on the idea that their
brothers and sisters
might still be alive somewhere all of
the children that
is except for john the one who'd
originally claimed he'd shaken his
siblings awake
but later changed his story john
never spoke about that night again
saying only that the event was behind
them
and that everyone should accept that
fact and move on
sylvia soder the youngest and last
surviving member of the family
died earlier this year without a final
answer as to what really happened
to her lost siblings
more recent expert opinions suggests it
may have been possible for the
children's remains to have been burnt up
completely in the fire
but alternative theories still abound
the most popular
assume that the children were taken as
punishment for george sodder's attacks
on mussolini
or revolve around george's background
somehow
george never spoke about his early life
in italy or why he'd come to the united
states sparking rumors that the mafia
had been responsible for kidnapping his
children
this idea was especially popular at the
time the supposed photograph of louis
soda came to light
part of the indecipherable message on
the back of the photo
was the number 90132
which used to be a zip code in palmero
sicily
strengthening the mafia connection
as far as mysteries go this has to be
one of the saddest around
either five young children died in that
fire
or they didn't either way something
truly tragic took place that night for
the people
left behind the soda family the events
of christmas 1945
tore their lives apart staunchly
believing their children had survived
the fire
they never found the closure that might
have let them
eventually move on instead
they searched unrelentingly for a truth
that may or may not have existed for the
decades that remained of their lives
in many ways the easiest version of
events to believe is the one put forward
at the time
that the children perished in the flames
much of the evidence to the contrary
missing gladders
strange phone calls in the night and
sporadic eyewitness accounts
is firmly circumstantial none of it
proves anything at
all and may only have served to give
false hope to a family
staring down the barrel of unimaginable
tragedy
and yet this is a story where so many
little things just seem off where
coincidences stack on top of
inconsistencies
to the point that there's just enough
reason to believe
the sodder children might already have
been gone
when the house caught fire whether they
were taken to be sold
to wealthy americans in an illegal
adoption scheme
that wasn't unheard of at the time
though it did tend to happen to younger
children
or whether they were spirited away as
punishment for george sodder's political
views
or some unknown event in the past
it's impossible to say and sadly
that sentiment sums this whole case up
we'll probably never know what really
happened that terrible christmas eve in
perhaps we should in the words of mafia
legend mickey blue eyes
forget about it
thanks for watching check out my new
podcast
random interesting facts available on
youtube
spotify apple podcast and anywhere else
you get your podcasts
link in the description below thanks